what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so the Superman reborn storyline
was really one of the most important
stories to come out of DC rebirth
because of Weber's nted and because of
what it established but what the Trinity
number eight tie-in does is actually
build on this now here's the crazy thing
coming after Superman reborn is a
storyline called Superman reborn
aftermath which crosses over into
Superman Action Comics a superwoman
Supergirl and it includes Trinity number
eight but in truth this is really more
of like an isolated one-shot it's really
standalone so we can really just kind of
do it in isolation and all we really
have to know is that Superman reborn
took place now here's why this matters
so much is because the way does Superman
reborn was written there was a lot of
ambiguity there were a lot of things
that were kind of curious to fans in
terms of what it all meant how it all
came together did the new 52 and pre new
52 Superman merged together what in the
world was going on what this does is
answer a lot of those questions and it
actually calls into question the very
nature of the story Superman Lois and
Clark and the reason why is because we
had covered that story and it is down
and as part of the Superman playlist for
for DC rebirth but what this story does
is seemed to shift it up it seems to
basically change it up all we really
knew was Superman Lois and Clark is that
Superman uh really the the premium 52
Superman Lois Lane and their son
Jonathan we're in the new 52 universe
previously that explanation was offered
by way of convergence and we don't need
to go into a great big huge explanation
about that all we can really get away
with saying here is that they were
basically removed from their own
universe and thrown into the new 52 what
this story does is offer a separate
alternative now this initially picks up
with the idea of the premium 52 and the
new 52 Superman fighting one another
it's actually really kind of cool
because the narrative is given to us by
the reborn Superman we'll go ahead and
call on that the narrative is given to
us by the reborn Superman is that this
is a dream sequence and he's not really
even sure what's going on but the
statements that are made by these two
guys as they're fighting you know
there's only one real Superman there's
only one true Man of Steel this is my
life these are my memories I'm not going
to let you take it away that kind of a
thing it hits home at the idea that not
everything is what it seems and so
leaving this dream state for a second we
basically pick up with Superman Wonder
Woman and Batman
because remember this is Trinity and so
this is designed to focus on the Trinity
the Holy Trinity of DC Comics Batman
Superman Wonder Woman
the top three characters in the DC
landscape is designed to focus on them
and them alone and so what we end up
doing is we actually have Superman
bringing Batman and Wonder Woman to the
fortress of solitude and the reason why
is because of the fact that Superman
recognizes that he is basically the
backbone of the Justice League in a lot
of different ways he's kind of like
their moral Center he's the guy that's
really kind of like the the foundation
by which it's all built which is to say
then when it all comes down to it
everybody looks to Superman as the guy
who's going to whisk in and save them
because he's the most powerful of all
the people on earth because of what you
stand for what he believes in in fact
he's fighting for families so he's not
just fighting for himself you know
different aspects of his character make
him this sort of bedrock of the Justice
League team the issue at this is that as
he talks to Batman and Wonder Woman he
basically conveys this notion that he's
not really sure what it is that's going
on more so than that he actually goes
back to the dream state and in the
middle of this conflict between himself
and the new 52 Superman Batman and
Wonder Woman join the fray and that's
why this is so cool is because it hits
home at the idea that the reborn
Superman doesn't know if they're
actually there in the dream if they were
conjured by him if their representations
of his fear in doubt because remember
he's not really sure of what's going on
right now he doesn't know if he was
merged into a singular being if he was
restored to the way it was before and
that's really what he's hitting at as he
talks to Wonder Woman and Batman he says
look maybe this is a scenario where all
of reality has been tinkered with maybe
what we're seeing here right now is not
the way things are supposed to be and
that makes sense because remember in DC
Universe rebirth number 1 Wally West had
basically showed up on the doorstep of
Barry Allen that the pre new 52 Wally
West showed up on the doorstep of Barry
Allen these various year as I said look
someone stole 10 years from our life the
implication seems to be here that the
whole idea of Superman Lois and Clark
the basis behind that storyline how
convergence led into it that does not
hold any standing anymore
what does matter essentially what's been
established here is that story in
isolation going into DC rebirth which is
to say if we go by that standard
suddenly the new the premium 52 Superman
and the pre new 52 Lois Lane and their
son Jonathan Kent we're just in the new
52 one day and no one knew how they got
there they didn't even know how they got
there they were just there they had
memories of a metropolis that doesn't
exist any
this kind of rolls that in and what it
seems to say here at least the
indication that's given to us here is
that in this time period when the ten
years were removed from everybody's life
that the old pre new 52 metropolis was
there presumably it's the original
metropolis it's the metropolis that was
there at the start of the new 52 that
you know this version of Superman that
we see here this Superman reborn was the
only Superman the only version that was
there during this 10-year window when
time was taken from people's lives and
presumably dr. Manhattan started messing
around with people's realities what he
seemed to do is whether he only did it
was to grin or anybody else we don't
know but what he seemed to do is
basically split Superman in two and then
just basically wipe everybody's minds of
how things are supposed to be and then
just sort of pick up with everything and
so that would explain why it is that
when the new 52 first started we had the
new 52 Superman we had the new 52 Batman
the new 52 one the woman is so on and so
forth and then the pre new 52 Superman
at least as he was listed was just there
and he was there during the first fight
with the Justice League he was there
when the superheroes first emerged but
didn't really know how he got there he
was just suddenly there so it really
kind of makes sense because it's
entirely possible that it played out
that way I mean if we were to follow
this timeline of events for example to
just kind of give things a little bit of
clarity for those of you guys who feel a
little bit lost if we were to go to this
timeline of events the way to do you see
initially presented it to us with the
new 52 is they said okay here is very
Alan going back in time to save his
mom's life all right he succeeds in
doing that that initiates the flashpoint
universe very Alan wakes up in a
flashpoint universe with his mom having
been saved and realizes that the world
has basically gone to pot in order for
the world to be the way that is supposed
to be he has to be the flash meaning his
mom has to die so he regains the Speed
Force powers with the help of Thomas
Wayne who became Batman instead of Bruce
because Bruce was shot instead of Thomas
and Martha Wayne the result is that
Barry Allen gets his powers he goes back
in time he stops himself from saving his
mom's life the new 52 is born when the
new 52 first came into existence
superheroes had only been around for
about five years
so humanity didn't trust them and then
all the stories that you read in the new
52 began to unfold
Batman 0 year Action Comics Superman
Justice League someone a so forth the
narrative best presented here were at
least a narrative that seems to be
hinting at here is that all of that
followed the exact same
patterns the difference is that when the
new 52 first started Superman as we see
him here was the Superman who was there
metropolis as we figured it from the pre
new 52 era is the metropolis that was
there all the superheroes as we knew
them before the new 52 were exactly the
same but dr. Manhattan's somebody with
extreme powers stepped in and basically
split Superman into presumably split all
the other superheroes into and then
turned around wipe everybody's mind
assumably removed the old-school
superheroes the premium 52 versions and
we went forward with the new 52 that
seems to be what happened that somewhere
along the line somebody did something
now that's just one indication of what
could have taken place here but Superman
hints back at the whole discussion that
he has with this new 52 version of
himself and he hints back at this dream
that he has in which case he basically
sees all these different versions of
Batman and Wonder Woman and Superman you
know all these different iterations of
themselves that join into the conflict
whether it's the old golden age Superman
from the 1930s you know whether it's
Superboy all these different versions of
himself just begin kind of cropping up
out of nowhere and flying in so the idea
seems to be that someone's messing with
the multiverse they're messing with
reality all these different iterations
of themselves again things are left
pretty ambiguous or left very
cloak-and-dagger by : bun the way he
writes this story and so it raises just
as many questions as it answers now I
have no doubt this will all be clarified
it'll all be cleaned out as we get
further into DC Comics especially with
the button story are coming to a close
on the 17th and so because of that
things are probably going to be pretty
clear and easy to understand but the
overall gist here is that Batman
Superman and Wonder Woman agree not to
tell anyone about this because if they
were to go to new you know go to the
Justice League with the news and
Superman were to say hey look guys I had
this experience where basically I merged
with my new 52 yourself to reform
Superman as I'm supposed to be I am a
wholly new personnel or at least I'm
back to my original state the same thing
seems to have been done with you guys
you've been split away from your
original iterations who you are now is
not really who you're supposed to be it
would destroy the Justice League because
nobody would know what's going on they
would literally just disband and race
off to figure out what's going on with
their own individual lives and they
would question all of the reality around
them dare I say it would push some of
them to the brink of insanity and so
because of that they agree to keep
everything
fine to keep everything closed now in
truth : but is doing this because it
just fits in with the charter of the
Trinity that's what the Trinity is they
deal with things on their own as a
singular group instead of involving the
Justice League now again we're only
eight issues in the story may expand by
the point that justice lee begins to get
rolled in but for the most part I would
say the Justice League would probably be
an ancillary part of the story with the
main focus being on the Trinity the
Justice League would exist to serve the
same purpose as a team up and then they
would go away as soon as the story's
over go back to doing whatever it is
that they normally do but the fact
remains here because of everything
that's going on because of all the
questions that are being brought up as a
result of you know Superman reborn mr.
Mitchell pedelec and all that kind of
good stuff
ultimately the goal of the Trinity
begins to shift away strictly from just
kind of focusing on events that are
taking place trying to deal with
conflicts and so on trying to find an
answer to the question of who is mr. Oz
and why does this guy have a role and
what it is is going on what is his role
is he an is he an observer is he a guy
who's just chronicling aventador taking
place is he working alongside dr.
Manhattan if he taking people like
doomsday removing them from the equation
if you're taking people like Tim Drake
removing them from the equation because
they're going to be needed later on I
mean these are the kind of things that
are happening taking them out of the DC
universe putting them and their own
little cells are basically a way of
keeping them from dying in order to make
sure that they they say a lot because
number that's how those characters play
out every single time mr. Oz took
someone and put them in a cell they were
on the brink of death Tim Drake was
going to die doomsday was going to die
all these different characters were
going to die mr. mixon pillock
presumably was going to die when the
whole flashpoint event took place
because of that they were taken by mr.
Oz and then thrown into his self
presumably kept in stasis so it could
just be that he held them so that they
could be used at a pre Revelator point
in time we have no idea what's happening
here if he's a friend instead of an
enemy or if he's an enemy instead of a
friend we don't know what his role is
and so again Trinity seems like it's
going to begin the process of giving us
a lot of the answers to this question
now in truth I would surmise that
Trinity will only be one facet of the
discussion that Justice League will give
us an answers we see that kind of
playing out in timeless but all these
ideas of well there's a threat coming
and you guys need to be prepared for
what's going to happen and so on and so
forth the entire multiverse is in
jeopardy
you know we see that with the flash and
Batman the button which is giving us
more answers than we've ever had before
we see that playing out in a lot of
different stories indecent comics so in
truth it'll probably just be some
massive line wide crossover event
they'll just span everything you know
once this whole thing said and done and
usher in the next stage of storytelling
but in any event if you guys are new
here to come as explained make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all at it peace
[Music]
you